الله اكبر
ما
السلام ورحمه
[Silence]
‏Ja.
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين اما بعد
فالدرس موصول في كتاب الطهاره
في باب ما يستحب له الوضوء
‏This is the chapter that weerday
morning
on the
instances the occasion
the actions in which is prerable
person have to do we mention as well a
revision
of those things which a person must have
to
هذه امور لابد
للانسان ان يكون متوضئا حتى يباشر هذه
الافعال الثلاثه
الصلاه
وضو الصلاه والثاني
الطواف
اند
الثالث
مس المصحف القران
طيب
[Silence]
الله
makeعاء
could
anything at any time however
is that the person who for instance
up makes
two faces
الله سبحانه وتالى
areذ
الله
ابن قنفذ
ما شاء الله مهاجر بن قنفذ
مهاجر بن قنفذ
حديث
مهاج بن قنفذ رضي الله عنه طيب
صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
ان لك في النهار سبحا طويلا يعني وقتا
طويلا تستريح به تستريح فيه
قيلوله
‏different nar
would us have
a person could
you have to gole
‏we usle at
take if gole afternoon many might think
those are only for the those are to
sleep not the time of day
وضو يقول لما رواه البراء ابن عازب
رضي الله عنه
قال قال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اذا
اتيت مضجعك فتوضا وضوءك للصلاه
اذا اتيت
مضجعك يعني المكان اللي تنام فيه فتوضا
وضوءك للصلاه يعني توظى في المضجع في ال
في الفراش تتوظفي لا اذا اتيت بالماضي هنا
بمعنى اذا اردت
مثل اذا قمتم الى الصلاه فاغسلوا وجوهكم
يعني اذا اردتم ان تصلي
البراء ابن عازب
الصلاه فتوضا وضوء للصلاه ثم اطجع على شقك
الايمن
ثم قل اللهم
اسلمت نفسي اليك
دعاء
ووجهت وجهي اليك
وفوضت امريك
والج ظهري اليك
رغبه ورهبه اليك
لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك
اللهم
امنت بكتابك الذي انزلت
ونبيك الذي ارسلته
يقول فان
من ليلتك
فانت على الفطره
واجعلهن اخر ما تتكلم به والحديث في
الصحيحين
فطره
توحيد
‏and make
all
عاذ
واجعلهن
اخر ما تتكلم به
امنت بكتابك الذي انزلت وبن نبيك الذي
ارسلت
very important
البراء ابن عازب
ل
اعيدهن عليك
صلى الله عليه وسلم
وامنتك
الذي ارسلت
الذي انزل
وبرسولك الذي ارسلت
نبي
رسول
صلى الله عليه وسلم
لا بل قل وبنبيك الذي ارسلت
take
دعاء
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
دعاء
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى على
البركه ان يبارك لنا في كتابه العظيم وان
ينفعنا جميعا بما فيه من الايات والذكر
الحكيم نساله تعالى ان يفقهنا في دينه وان
يستعملنا ولا يستبدلنا والله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد